all right my friends dozens of you
sending me this clip overnight of course
i'm going to mention it radical
republican congresswoman marjorie taylor
green
is very confused and when she wanted to
attack
nancy pelosi's gestapo tactics
she referred to
gazpacho gazpacho the cold
spanish tomato soup
and my reaction was this woman is such a
dumb bisque i mean really it uh
let's
let's take a look at the video
um
you know much like trump flushing
documents down the toilet as we learned
about this morning
this is the type of thing where
if it was part of a if it was part of a
screenplay it would get removed because
it would just not be believable
here is marjorie taylor green herself
take a listen not only do we have the dc
jail which is the dc gulag but now we
have nancy pelosi's gazpacho police
spying on members of congress fine
oh man if you missed it here it is one
more time
which is the dc gulag but now we have
nancy pelosi's gazpacho police spying on
members of as alexandria ocasio-cortez
tweeted
this is what happens when you ban books
from your house
uh this woman has gone completely lentil
i'm sorry mental i'm sorry now i'm
getting all soup soup confused no i mean
listen it's uh
as a reminder the gestapo was the german
secret police of the nazis in third
reich
world war ii era germany gazpacho is a
vegetable
tomato
cold soup typical in spain
um i like blending a cucumber into it
people care about gazpacho that i i
think you get a really nice not only
taste but also in terms of the smell
uh throwing in one little cucumber
persian cucumber maybe it really helps
but nancy pelosi i can assure you
is not enforcing any soup related rules
here on the floor of the house and it's
beyond these people are caricatures of
their caricatures of themselves if you
wanted to ridicule someone like marjorie
taylor green
you couldn't actually come up with
something wackier and more absurd
than her trying to say these
authoritarians with their gazpacho
it's you you can't it's too on the nose
it's there's no way to actually make it
any crazier and uh listen if you hire
stupid people to represent you in the
house of representatives you're going to
get stupid gaffes and that's exactly
what we're getting and she's a joke and
she will almost certainly be reelected
think about what this means about the
people of georgia who are going to vote
for her they're they're almost certainly
going to re-elect her to the house of
representatives
uh they're they look at us the world
over and they laugh they point and they
laugh and sometimes they cry
when they feel bad for us if they're in
an empathetic mood
absolutely humiliating
one of our sponsors is established
titles if you're looking for a perfect
last minute valentine's day gift check
this out it's funny it's unique and
they're supporting a great cause
established titles is a project based on
the historic scottish custom where
landowners are called lords and ladies
and so established titles lets you
ceremonially
buy as little as one square foot of
dedicated land in aberdeenshire scotland
so that you can call yourself a lord or
lady you get an official certificate
with a crest they let you see exactly
where your spot is located
but in return for each one sold
established titles will plant a tree to
protect the beautiful pristine woodlands
of scotland established titles also
supports global charities like one tree
planted and trees for the future so it's
a fun gift but you're also helping to
support something great and right now
they're having a huge valentine's day
sale on top of that you'll get an extra
10
off when you go to establish titles dot
com slash pacman and use the code pacman
the link is down below